welcome to beautiful Vancouver British
Columbia this is actually where I grew
up just across that water and I remember
when I was a teenager here I wanted to
be a filmmaker and so what did I do well
I found a film director with a strange
name who lived in Vancouver I saw her on
the cover of this magazine and then I
just looked up her number in the phone
book and the white pages because that's
how you did and back in the year 2000
and I gave her a call and she said she
was on the other line but she'd called
me back and strangely enough she did
call me back and it was amazing I got to
chat to her about filmmaking I guess
what I really wanted was for someone
else to be able to provide me with an
opportunity to get on set to get some
experience in that industry and show me
what it's like I just want to know and
it's so hard when you're on the outside
to figure out how to break in you just
want to reach out to someone who knows
and say help me with this there is a
psychological phenomenon known as
learned helplessness and the experiments
conducted way back decades ago that
established this phenomenon were really
quite terrible what they would do is
take dogs and for some of them at least
they would force them to endure a
punishment for example they would
receive electric shocks and there was
nothing they could do to prevent those
shocks for other dogs
there were actually little levers or a
fence they could hop over that would
stop the shocks now later on they took
all of those dogs and they tested them
again but in environments where every
one of those dogs had the opportunity to
avoid the shocks by taking some action
now what was found was those dogs that
had been forced to injure the shocks and
had no way of stopping them just kind of
came to accept the shocks even when
there were actions that they could take
which would stop them so this is learned
helplessness they have learned there's
nothing they can do to stop that
uncomfortable situation there's a
related study carried out with adults
where they were trying to complete a
task except there was this distracting
noise playing now some of the adults had
the ability to turn off that noise
whereas others did not it was not under
their control
when you look at the performance the
adults who had the control to turn off
the noise performed better even when
they didn't actually exercise that
control so they just let the noise play
but the knowledge that they could shut
it off if they wanted to made them
perform better I have worked at many
jobs now some very menial and some more
managerial or entrepreneurial like I was
basically running the show and what I
found is that there's kind of this
divide between employees and managers
when you're an employee and you're
assigned to do something you try to do
it as best you've been shown but if you
hit a roadblock you kind of stop and you
go to your manager or supervisor and you
say hey what do I do now now I've done
that before I've done it when I was a
research assistant I've get some result
I didn't really know what was going on
and I just take it to my supervisor the
supervisor would say oh well why don't
you try this and that suggestion that
they made was always one that I knew or
you know I could have thought of if I
just spent five minutes on it or if I
really wanted to achieve that goal but
instead I just had this mentality like
I'm carrying out this task and when I
get stuck I'm just gonna ask someone
else you know there's a story that Tim
Ferriss tells he's the guy who wrote the
4-hour workweek which is a book I would
recommend but he went and visited this
University and he challenged the
students that he was talking to he said
look I will give you $25,000 in a trip
around the world for anyone who shows
that they have made contact by some sort
of signature email a letter or something
with either Jennifer Lopez Bill Clinton
who I think at the time was the
president possibly and JD Salinger who's
the most reclusive writer of all time
and did anyone do it nope not a one now
the following year he went back to the
same University and in addition to
making a challenge he told them the
story from the previous year that no one
had actually done it no one had really
tried in that year six people actually
achieved his challenge the point being
you need to find a way around the
learned helplessness mentality the
employee mentality and find a way to
realize that things the
seem impossible can be accomplished if
you really accept that you have control
of these things that it's not outside of
your control it may be a question we
should ask is does our school system
promote learned helplessness do we force
kids to suffer punishment that they
really can't change time and time and
time again and then we expose them to a
world and say now you go out and do what
you want to do I think to a certain
degree we are doing that you know school
is for a lot of kids just a weird and
unusual kind of punishment and I guess
it's no wonder that they learn that you
know there's things beyond their control
because school is kind of about taking
control away from kids you know for the
dogs how did they get the dogs to
overcome their learned helplessness and
actually get away from the shocks they
were receiving they tried treats and
encouragement but it didn't work they
had to physically move the dogs away
from the area where they were being
shocked at least twice before they would
actually learn that they had the power
to change their faith that they didn't
have to suffer that kind of punishment
again and again but with you I feel like
just letting you know that this thing
exists might be enough to change the way
you view your life and your
opportunities let's talk briefly about
career paths I applied to acting school
three times and was rejected three times
I applied to film school twice and was
rejected twice I think what I was
looking for out of those institutions
was a surefire way to get to the career
that I wanted I was basically doing the
same thing that I was doing when I asked
that director in Vancouver to help me
out to get me on set I was asking for
someone else to make this possible for
me I mean there's a small number of jobs
where the career path is clearly laid
out you want to be a doctor you have to
go to med school you want to be a lawyer
you have to go to law school you want to
be a academic you have to do a PhD but I
think there's a much larger group of
careers where you really have to figure
out a way to do it yourself
and that's the whole point that is the
whole challenge you feel like you're not
in control and you want someone else to
help you get that control or get in the
place where you need to be but no one
can really help you just like that
director couldn't really help me get
where I need to be
I cannot help other people get where
they need to be you really have it all
up to you I mean you have to demonstrate
that you can do what you want to do you
know there is this quote grant me the
serenity to accept the things I cannot
change and the courage to change the
things I can and the wisdom to know the
difference now my point is when you're
contemplating the things that you can
and cannot change err on the side of
thinking that you can change much more
than you can because often you will be
able to I mean everything seems
impossible until it's done that's a
Nelson Mandela quote which i think is
kind of appropriate in this circumstance
things look a lot more impossible than
they are and really it's up to you to
find out
wife's hey as you can tell books have
had a huge impact on my life and how I
see the world and when I'm traveling I
like to listen to them as audiobooks
because it's just more convenient on
planes and trains and there's actually
what I want to recommend to you it is
called predictably irrational by Dan
O'Reilly it's about how humans don't
really behave rationally even when we
think that's what we're doing so it
provides pretty good insight into how
your brain works and how the brains of
everyone around you work and if you want
you can download this book for free by
going to audible.com/veritasium or you
can pick any other book of your choosing
for a one-month free trial audible is a
great audiobook website with over
180,000 titles in all areas of
literature including fiction nonfiction
and periodicals so you should definitely
check them out
I want to thank audible for supporting
me and I want to thank you for watching